[Music]
around me
hey babe hey babe yearning is a I gotta
be honest actually let me take this to
you if you have a mic I just wanted just
a quick female question if I said let's
say you know you like me whatever gonna
if I said I'm yearning for you but you
could be like that's too much yeah wait
are you texting it to me are you telling
me I'm telling you we're at dinner we've
already say we've already went on a
couple of dates we've already
established like this is not like I'm
not opening up with this you've you like
me you know like like you're we're
dating and I say I'm yearning for you is
that to me it's a little much I couldn't
take that what do you think of Yearning
if a guy says that too they said it to
me I think I'd be like this is since
every line has been played out this is
wow
see you is a little much like yeah urine
a urine is like uh yeah yearning is
that's like an old days I think people
used to yearn because because that's
that's why I'm bringing up because when
you look at all letters from Napoleon
when you look at old Love Letters from
famous people yeah it was all like I'm I
I miss you so much I want to cut my art
out and feed it to the soldiers yes
people be like I love you yeah where now
you like can't like now if I was single
I would be scared to even tell a woman
she's pretty like you know like you
wouldn't want to yeah because you're
like I don't know but so yearning is
like you're I thought you'd be taking a
swing to tell a woman I gotta I gotta I
got an idea here we go okay you go home
later today okay I go home later today
we don't tell you don't tell your lady I
don't tell my lady okay I want you to
turn on your voice recorder hit hit
record okay put it down on the counter
and then talk 10 20 seconds just so it
doesn't look like it's a joke and just
be like it's a long day I really I I
really yearned for you today or like
let's get the line like oh just babe I
love you I always yearn for you say it
seriously okay let's see how they each
react okay and then here's what we do we
record it and the honest truthful
reactions we will post on the next
week's episode yes the honest truthful
whatever they say even if they don't
care if whatever ever it is that's what
okay okay yeah deal yeah okay deal yeah
all right so so I just want to make one
thing so it's evil like we're getting
the same
I we need a constant so we know that
we're both getting the response off the
same thing because okay that'll be
better so like how do you want to say it
like okay so I think I'll go home I'll
get home and I'll you know she'll say
how was your day or or you know or take
the [__] trash out or you know your
daughter's had a fever for all day what
the [__] are you doing you know you're
getting paid to have fun I'm here with
the [__] kids yes whatever's going on
yes and and you know which is acceptable
she's you know I get it I'll go through
the similar thing yes and so and so so
so so what I'm gonna say is babe I know
that I just want to let you know like
okay okay no because you had especially
you had to be careful how you deliver it
because you because it away right yeah
you do if you give it away yeah we don't
have anything yeah you know oh she I
mean don't get me wrong she might be
like you idiot like I know you're joking
like and that's it is what it is but if
you can do everything in your power
you know maybe like maybe let it record
for like a half hour like like get get
get we won't hear that part but like get
it so that you get to a that organ like
sentimental conversation naturally
you're not blinding signing her with you
I'm yearning right now right right so I
want to say okay so but are we saying
yearning or yearn well this is what
we're trying to start right is it in the
action of or did I was I Yearning For
You past tense am I yearning for you now
do I yearn for you in perpetuity yeah
maybe I yearn for you in perpetuity
right maybe it's I learned for you yeah
maybe it's just like you know I don't
know dude everything's been so stressful
lately I just you know I was just
thinking about you I'm glad I have you
as a support system in my life I love
you as a matter of fact I I'm always
yearning for you
just let it lie let the yearn just float
out there yeah and see if they say if
it's like oh thank you and it's like
it's an un really underwhelming like
thank you I took you serious I didn't I
don't know maybe I didn't even hear what
you did like they didn't catch the urine
then just be like yeah no of course of
course you know I yearn fine okay drop
it again done because they had to
address the urine in some 100 way shape
or form I'm in I'm gonna I'm gonna I
swear to God I'm gonna do it okay yearn
for you yeah okay now what are some
possible responses what do you think
you're betting on like do you think that
she would if you pull it off do you
think she'll be able to receive the
yearn in a in a serious matter and say
to you that it's sweet or that I feel
the same or something like that or do
you think there's no shot in hell you're
dropping the word yearn and it's not
going to be called out I'm not even
being funny I'm being dead serious if I
Know Her Like I think I know her because
when I've I've said words like that
before or whatever like not even trying
to do a joke yeah she's gonna be she's
gonna it's gonna be like that I'm gonna
say she's gonna go did you just say he
earned for me I'm gonna be like yeah
she'd be like you're an [__] yeah
okay okay but just make sure the best
you can that it seems sincere and
organic and she's not blindsided because
then it's gonna sound hokey okay okay
yeah all right and if you end up saying
you're like I learned for you today I
yearned for you today is too much I
think it's too jokey but if you just say
like you know I love you so much I'm
always yearning for you you know
something like that you know what I mean
yeah yeah yeah okay all right good yeah
because because I just when I heard that
word yearning I just thought
you know I I don't know it's interesting
I wonder what what the people think at
home according to V
like it can't there's a large
possibility it can be taken
like genuinely yeah because like
I you know what about longing yearnings
worse Longing To synonyms yeah it's
learning I think it's just so is a is a
older version yeah yeah yeah yeah right
yeah I think because you know I I I
don't know in this world like I feel
like even a woman saying to a man like I
just feel like it's dicey to
kind of complement someone these days
because it can just be taken in so many
different way man to woman woman to man
yeah but I still think ultimately like I
still think ultimately
if a woman even like a devout feminist
was walking down the block and a guy was
like yo yo you got a fat ass Oh I
thought he was like yo sure
they would be upset by it but also it
has to make you feel nice it's just same
thing as a guy if a guy was like a
devout you know like hey she was like yo
shorty Yoshi you got a fat ass yeah it's
got to make you feel good I don't know
about that for a man though does a man
want a fat ass p-h p-h or F I've been
told multiple times by by different
women that I have a fat ass and I don't
know if that's a good thing or a bad
thing it does make me feel I am the most
self-conscious of any part of my body of
my ass okay so I am the same as the
women in my family okay we all have the
same body issues where I do feel I have
a bit of a bare ass okay which
pair yes and then the problem is it
comes it comes to a point at the bottom
it almost looks like a like a regular
slice of pizza like it's wide and then
it comes to a point and that can't be
good a point yes
Jasmine is telling me my ass looks like
a scalene triangle
laughs
she told me that word for where it was a
scaly Google scalene triangle please
I don't know if she knew what scalene
was but would you say that I I was I was
I was in shock
so a scalene
which ones are scaling scaly is the one
that looks like a pizza different
lengths okay she's told me hey she told
me what your ass looks like a scalene
triangle dude she you
Jesus Christ
I mean that's that's insane I was ready
to go to college what's that did your
lady go to college yes okay four years
uh yes yeah fit okay yeah I think I
don't think College college to me isn't
going to be as necessary
right now sister going to go to college
your little sister
she dropped out of high school she
dropped out of high school yeah yeah In
fairness so she's going to college home
school that you were in homeschooled as
well go to sixth grade but then you went
to college though yeah right and I went
back to high school homeschooling's
coming back in yes wait wait you dropped
out of six then what happened you got
home schooled for the rest of it yeah uh
for a couple years and I went back you
dropped out of six it's your choice
yeah so then do you not know the things
they taught in seventh and 8th grade
what they teach I don't know hit me with
some of it I don't know um did you ever
feel the lack of the seventh eighth
grade
you know um I just never started doing
pills right yeah pills in 17th grade
times
seventh eighth grade what I remember
from seventh eighth grade remember from
seventh grade there that was big science
I think that was big on science we
learned a lot about uh the oceans and
things like that and history big history
and now my I have a stepson who's in
seventh grade they learned they don't
write a book report on 9 11. that was
his summer
where were you that people were popping
pills in seven eighth grade White Stone
Queens outer Queens outer Queens baby oh
that's that's that's uh that's Bleak
yeah yeah what type of pills Xanax from
their parents oh no from other
neighborhood kids they're getting into
it early now yeah yeah yeah no dude I I
know a kid they could 13 I felt he rode
a dirt bike to Pennsylvania last weekend
13 years old on a dirt bike to
Pennsylvania
these kids these kids it's just like a
different word they've grown up so fast
dirt bike to Pennsylvania his kid's mom
he literally he could she was on
vacation you know the son I guess was
with her dad and she tracks his phone
and all of a sudden we're like hanging
out everyone's hanging out she calls
whatever her husband's name and she goes
why is our son in Pennsylvania he goes
what are you talking about she goes she
goes like he was told he's taking his
dirt bike around the neighborhood she
goes check his phone he's in
Pennsylvania on the dirt bike and then
and so that's great I almost want my kid
instead to do his local one Xanax
instead yeah that's I mean it's less
it's less dangerous to take a dirt bike
to Pennsylvania if I had to choose gun
to head just take the pill mellow out
we'll talk about how bad it is after
right but otherwise the all the other
cars are also a dirt bike like like two
or three hours see people the debate
with parents
is like do you want your kid like is is
parenting harder when your kids are
small like in diapers or older when
they're
see different types are hard which
that's what I am right now
um and that's just talking about diapers
that's your new special
yeah
um so I but I kiss my St kiss my scalene
triangle yeah I so I because I'm I have
the phases of it I have 13 8 and 2 and I
gotta tell you yeah Far and Away the
hardest is the two-year-old oh really
far and away because no no but what
about 16 17 18 okay so Grant we haven't
got there yet yeah but it's yes it's
difficult to negotiate at times with a
13 year old and an eight-year-old and
the mental stuff is hard and of course
worrying about them when they go out but
I but the physical everyday they're
walking the diapers
that part for me I'm I'm you want every
moment of it is beautiful but I but I do
I it's it's so exhausting that's the
thing like you're sleep deprived and you
know it's very difficult it's beautiful
because she that's why I think nature
makes babies so cute because you're like
yeah if not you'd be like
it would have a human race yeah so but
but it's interesting I I saw I Googled
it I said what was what was the magical
age where parenting gets easier and they
pulled like thousands of parents six age
six is when things start to get there's
enough remarkably easier because you can
Independence because they'll sit in a
restaurant you don't have to change
their diaper they'll just sit in the car
you don't have to have a car seat a
stroll or a bag of diapers yeah
everything you can go to the beach and
they won't like they'll listen to you
right things like that sick so that
that's because right now it's beautiful
but it's like if I want to go out to eat
with our family we of course do it we
don't deprive ourselves but it's tough
with a two-year-old yeah because she's
gonna throw [__] and throw the
breadsticks you're going to say oh my
God at any given moment yeah she said
that when the tree was down she did so
funny she so she's using it correct no
she's but she didn't say mine she saw
the train she went oh [__] oh [__] like
that she like runs around so she knows
what she said she knows what she's
saying yeah yeah that's good that's fun
but yeah so I think I think because I
I'm in that because I've made a decision
that why not that I've made the decision
but Jazz like no more kid like we're not
gonna do yeah so if the only time I
would I have another kid is if like if
you know Jasmine and I like broke up and
I would have like a 55 year old midlife
crisis and like you know right you know
got some 25 year old girl pregnant right
like you know like that's very specific
that's the only way that would ever
happen
um and uh and and so so it's interesting
because I'm like now that we've made a
decision we didn't even realize that we
were struggling with this but now that
her and I both said we will not have
another child we don't want another
child it's like now the the thought of
like her
but that you're all like getting out of
diapers or whatever it's almost like the
stress is gone because we're like every
day it's getting closer and so you're
not gonna bring it back yeah you know so
so I I don't know sometimes it's
interesting like you like these thoughts
are like occupy I think a lot of times
we're so stressed in life because we're
straddling a decision and we haven't
made one conclusive step you just
describe my day-to-day life brain every
second what causes it's what causes 99
of our stress because you haven't made a
choice once you make a choice and you
live with that choice good or bad
when you found out you were pregnant
with Violet right were you like holy
[__] dude like God bless I can't yeah
beautiful but like I was like how am I
going to give birth
no but it's like were you just like oh
my God remembering like the sleepless
not like holy I gotta go back into the
breach you don't in my opinion we didn't
remember how hard it was with us again
you went and told there was one night
where I was like crying all night and
you're like oh holy [__] yeah I don't
know I might go crazy
my cousin is Maya she's on her fifth
child who fifth child
she's got the oldest one is eight and
the youngest one I think is two and
pregnant with another one and God bless
her she the one thing I'll say about my
cousin she I have never heard her
complain once about being she loves it
and she does a great job so it's like
you have to be that person she's got to
be that person because five kids you are
saying my life is completely on a back
burner every second of every day for the
next decade or whatever it is right
whatever it is you
and some people
if they if that's what they want if
that's what they yearn for right then
then they're in it like this is what I
want I I my identity is this I want to
bring my you know I I thrive off in this
nature but like for for other people
it's like it's like you you don't
realize still until it happens probably
right that you you just your life is
forever forever changed yeah like you
like um like think about a Hasidic
Jewish woman like a lot of them have
like 15 plus kids their entire but I
think that's a strategy I think when
they have enough energy I think when
they have enough then maybe maybe I
imagine like all 15 it's like hey right
yeah like then it's almost like what's
another one have enough that have enough
that like you're really not concerned
they're all over the place they're
running around they help each other
there's nothing more about it yeah you
know it is but I have so many like I
can't because you can't focus on just
one of them you have to literally divide
your love your time your attention
between 15 kids that's a whole nother
thing because they're only getting one
fifteenth of your yeah there's only like
10 names in the Hebrew what are the
names what are the big names we got
David you got uh moisha yeah you got um
Rachel
you got Sarah
you got um
moisture
who's the
Rachel Rachel you got you got uh David
Abigail Esther okay Estee okay
um what else do you got Jesus Raphael
Ari Matthew Mark Luke and John Arielle
Arielle Rafi that's it that's the 15.
those are the names yeah I can't think
of another Modi
[Laughter]
yeah that's it
no I mean uh you know I think that
that's Australia 15's too much right
yeah because what exactly is happening
there with 15 kids what do you need 15
kids yeah it almost how do you support
15 kids how do you educate 15 kids well
because how do you feed 15 well that's
the thing it the debate is it it Teeters
it Teeters on narcissism and Teeters on
egomaniac it Teeters on that where
you're like I'm sure there's a reason to
people who like I love children I have
baby fever whatever but it is crazy
how what percentage of people have over
10 kids what's the number eight
what percentage of people in the United
in the United States have over eight
kids yeah I want to say less than 10
percent
it's got to be less than how many kids
is considered a large family
okay what do we got you can read that I
can't
I can't I can never read graphs like
this I never know what it means like if
you like a Venn diagram and a bubble
chart I'm like yeah I don't know I don't
know why yeah these shots then you're
looking on the side the left the right
then they give these units but then they
don't really oh wait oh wait can you can
you put that back so 50 340 people have
no children fourteen thousand have one
child 12 000 F2 7 000 have three or more
what is this out of who number of
families in the United States by number
of children under 18 living in the
household from 2000 to 2002 I don't know
what this is
I mean under 18. like the kids who are
under 18. but how many families have oh
that eight or more children it's got to
be a low percentage although within
vitro now a lot of people do have a lot
of kids because they have triplets in
one shot yeah having five or more kids
is generally the cutoff point for being
considered a large family here are the
ways you're around can you go back can
you go down to what is the happiest
family size right there
four children wow tell your family to at
least four children according to a study
out of Australia's Edith Cohen
University parents with the most life
satisfaction which means those who are
the happiest are those who have four or
more yeah and and the best is to have
two boys and two girls so each one has a
sibling that of the same sex and the
opposite sex that they can speak to
average person with a family typical
American picture of a family with 2.5
kids might not be as relevant as it once
was in 2022 there was an average of 1.94
children under 18 per family in the
United States this is a decrease from
2.33 children under 18. oh no make no
mistake the amount of people not having
kids these days is that nobody's having
kids like it's right it's it's getting
rarer and rarer and nobody's no less or
people having children in a much older
age also how rare is it to have 1.94
kids that's listen again with you know
with that's you know within vitro yeah
with all the yeah that's uh is that kids
too many yeah listen Eight is Enough
Eight is Enough it's it's
yeah what can you do but I'm practicing
now when I go on the road or when I have
to leave my family I'm practicing being
where my feet are that's my new motto be
where your feet are so don't leave half
your mind home with your family even
though you're yearning to be take your
whole mind with you and be present with
two feet wherever you are just like
you'll be present with two feet when you
get home because half the time how do
you stop the unit brain is my brain is
you know back home and then my I only
have half my brain where I'm at half my
brain isn't doing me any good where I'm
at and isn't doing them any good where
they're at so you'd rather just be all
in one place and then this way you'll be
but it's difficult it's it's the hardest
thing ever is to stay in the present if
that's why they call the press and the
present it's again it's a gift yes if
Jazz says to you uh would you say like
oh you you're out having fun that your
job is flying around here right and you
could say babe all I'm doing when I
leave this house
is yearning and earning that's it I'm
yearning in the morning and they're both
for you right then yeah that's nice
that's very sweet that would say yeah
yearning and earning yearning yeah I
like that don't say that today
maybe I would I mean the a thing
sometimes I don't know what I'm going to
walk into so I just try to walk in Happy
present and whatever it is it is what I
usually my go-to move is usually when I
just so I look like I'm doing something
I start loading and unloading the
dishwasher that's my go-to move I start
washing the dishes I understand so
you're loading and unloading so I'm
doing something yeah even if the dishes
were watched already I do them again
I actually find myself doing dishes too
yeah yeah she's always like just put in
the dishwasher and I'm like well do you
rinse and put them in the dishwasher
because I'll do it but I like wash them
and put them in the rack could we talk
about this before if you could only pick
one a dishwasher or washing machine
which would you pick
you can only have one in the house is it
a dishwasher or washing machine what do
you do if you don't have a washing
machine washer dryer well I'm saying do
you wanna do you wanna have the ability
to wash your clothes oh like just you
have to Outsource it like go to a
laundromat that or you can put them out
on a clothesline but that's a dryer wait
so obviously if I don't have a
dishwasher I'll wash the dishes by hand
if I don't have a washer babe it is late
August going right into September and
you know what that means to me what that
means the old pigarus and NFL is here
and DraftKings sports book is back baby
the official sporting sports betting
partner of the NFL is giving you a can't
miss offer for week one this week new
customers can get 200 in bonus bets
instantly when you bet just five bucks
on any NFL game DraftKings is hooking
everyone up with game day greatness all
customers can take advantage of two new
offers every single game day this
September check the app to see what you
get absolutely download now and use the
code be able to sign up new customers
can take home two hundred dollars in
bonus bets instantly just by betting
five bucks that's code hey babe only on
DraftKings Sportsbook an official sports
betting partner of the NFL the crown is
yours and you think I'm playing games
that's on my phone right now I don't
really you know you got stored you need
to you got limited storage space Oh yeah
I'm sorry but I gotta delete that but I
I I
only the only thing I do
a thing I do it every Sunday morning I
wake up before the game start and I
place my bets and it makes watching the
games for me a little more exciting
because I got something going on in
their fellow juice
gambling problem
no a 1-800 Gambler or visit www
just three 1-800 gambo.net in New York
call
877-8 Hope NY or text Hope NY
to four six seven three six nine in
Connecticut help is available for
problem gaming gambling uh calling
888-789-777 or visit
ccpg.org please play responsibility and
listen on behalf of Boot Hill Casino and
Resort in Kansas 21 plus age varies by
jurisdiction void in Ontario as it
usually is uh
ccdkng.com football for eligibility
terms and responsible gaming resources
bonus bets expired seven days after
issuance eligibility eligibility and
deposit restrictions apply again shout
out to Boot Hill Casino and Resort
all right babe listen you know I love to
travel and I've talked about this app
before this is the app I use every
single time I travel and it's called
Viator Viator 300 000 bookable travel
experience travel experiences in over
190 countries okay they've got simple
tours to Extreme Adventures I've used it
in Ireland I've used it in Scotland I
used it in Italy you could even use it
in America it's the best Viator it just
makes everything so easy I went on like
this haunted ghost tour in Scotland and
scared the [__] out of me and it was
amazing and I gave the guy five star
reviews and then I went even went on one
in England and I went all around England
and the tour guide and I became friends
and I think at one point or another I'm
probably gonna marry him download the
Viator app now and use code viator10 for
10 off your first booking one app over
300 000 experiences you'll remember do
more with Viator viator's travel
experiences have millions of real
traveler review so you can check them
out I am not lying if you don't believe
me just look at the reviews Viator is
the best travel experience is the best
best app to use for travel it's amazing
and um I love it and most of all I love
you Viator via tour 10 for 10 off your
first booking all right ding dong oh
hello fresh it is hellofresh oh wow what
is hellofresh well with hellofresh you
get farm fresh pre-portioned ingredients
and seasonal recipes delivered right to
your doorstep skip trips to the grocery
store and count on hello fresh to make
home cooking easy fun and affordable
that's why it's America's number one
meal kid and I look if you listen to
this podcast you've heard us talk about
hell of ours you knew that already right
I say that for the newcomers right
because all we get a lot of new audience
these days and they need to know for me
I've said goodbye Supermarket hello
fresh that's exactly right okay now
when it comes to options honestly
honestly more is more yeah that's why
hellofresh menu includes 40 recipes and
over 100 add-on items to choose from
every single week a busy fall schedule
doesn't always leave you leave with time
to spare and with hello fresh you don't
need to spend all evening in the kitchen
to whip up a wholesome meal no no they
got the quick and easy recipes and 15
minute meals you get a tasty dinner on
the table in less time than it takes to
get take out or deliver it's top-notch
produce and it's going from the farm to
your door it's not it's more than just
dinners as well they have uh breakfast
lunches snacks and everything in between
share uh can you just just scroll a
little bit there with him please go to
hellofresh.com five zero hey babe and
use code five zero hey babe for 50
percent off plus fifteen percent off the
next two months
that's pretty insane that's so it's 65
off it's 50 off initially and then 15
off for two strings yeah yeah this is
yeah hellofresh.com 50 hey babe use the
code 50 hey babe 50 off plus 15 off the
next two months yeah that's insane again
we always say we don't even know how
they they give their food away for free
and
listen just go go to hellofresh right
now put in that promo code get the
discount it's America's number one meal
capes all right everybody guess what we
added a show and in Irvine California
September 6 a late show has been added
so go get those tickets everything else
is sold out Portland September 8th is
sold out September 9 Seattle we have
limited tickets if you want to see me in
Seattle go get them Radio City New York
City September 22nd the show is sold out
we potentially might open up some
tickets but I believe it is fully sold
out September 23rd theater at Madison
Square Garden that's your shop to come
see me in New York City and then
September 30th Las Vegas at the cosmo
christycomedy.com for Tinky Wiki's brand
new hour of material this will be my new
hour that I'm putting out so come see it
live yes hey don't you dare skip this
okay this weekend September 8th I'm at
the Syracuse Funny Bone for the weekend
and then I'm rounding that off in
September going to Bowling Green
Kentucky Cincinnati Ohio and Toledo Ohio
and there's more dates on and on through
December uh savocano comedy.com right
now Syracuse I'll see you this coming
weekend also Sal vulcano official on
YouTube please subscribe uh once a week
week starting in two weeks I'm going to
be giving away a prize every single week
to only the people that are subscribed
to my YouTube I'm pulling the winners
from there it could be anything from a
prop from the show free tickets to see
me autographed posters a set visit and
actually if we get to 500 000
subscribers I will pull a winner out of
those subscribers to go to dinner with
me and Joe Gatto so that's that also if
you haven't got it get shipfaced
cruise.com come on the Impractical
Jokers and Eric Andre Cruz in January
2024 we're almost sold out check that
out everything's available right now
savvalcano comedy.com and we're making
tickets a little more affordable because
I want to reach all of my audience so if
you you know if you're on a budget check
it out this tickets for you as well well
if you I'm saying you can only have one
unit you can either have a washer dryer
combo in the house or you could have a
dishwasher which one would you pick to
have in the house
which task do you want to do less that's
a good that's a good taste buds can you
write that down here you go
choose one only use one oh that's that's
a good one buddy I gotta I gotta I I
feel like I'm in a crummy mood I'm like
the issues will be more of a nuisance
for sure right and I guess like
do you mean that then you have to wash
your clothes and hang your clothes or do
you mean that like I could then drop it
off at the laundromat you could drop it
back to me and fold it you could drop it
off that feels like a cheat okay so you
have to do your wash old school and put
them on a clothesline with clothes you
got to put you got to go to the
laundromat yeah my aunt by the way my
aunt right now in present-day America
still has a clothesline and uses it
every week she does her laundry in the
yard or whatever she has it over there
yeah she has it it doesn't feel weird
like having like everyone like of the
neighbors if they could just look and
see your drawers and also what about
bird [__] yeah how many times do you
have your clothes out there drying and a
bird shits on them do you know that my
grandparents had the clothesline indoors
length of the attic
full length of the whole attic okay so
then that that that's the that's the
kind of cheat code then yeah
they only had a washing machine because
I would think the thing is bird [__] and
then how many times there's a random
especially in the summer Rogue Storm
come and the clothes that were dry on
the quality bed now yeah knock yeah yeah
yeah you don't want to it's a lost art I
think and then what are you gonna do
especially like back in the olden days
like what are you gonna do you're an old
school guy what are you gonna put you
know say you got to America you're gonna
put your Nazi uniform out there to dry
you can't do that yeah you found out
right away yeah
here's what I don't get capacity issues
with clothes lines you have more clothes
than we'll hang on a line so if you do a
lot of laundry and it's soaking wet and
you can only put up so much on that line
what's happening to the other pile of
soaking my clothes still you got to put
it in a dry place or keep it in the sun
or I don't know okay well I think what
do you think I think I would do I'll
tell you what I think I would do
I think I would do
I would sacrifice a dishwasher
I think I would have a washer dryer for
my clothes interesting and you don't
mind hand washing a dish well here's
what I feel
if I do the dish that I used every time
as soon as I'm done and make it part of
like right then then it won't pile up or
if it piles up and I say all right no
that's bad because then you got to do
dishes but you could do laundry like
once uh every two weeks true yeah and
you can wear the same underwear a couple
of days in a row
yeah I went to San Diego I was only
there for 24 hours but I didn't bring a
change of underwear socks
well you know what I was gonna say
that's that's wild but then again if you
needed it you could have bought it I
could have brought it she's smart it was
stupid then I didn't but I didn't
survived you ever go like exactly what
you just did doesn't it feel amazing
when you're going to like an overnight
or a weekend and you have the clothes on
you once one little light bag of clothes
something and you feel like you're
underpacked but don't you feel amazing
amazing like you just feel light on your
feet like you just feel like oh packing
like there's nothing it almost makes you
feel like even going there and coming
back is like not too bad it's the key to
life I didn't even when they were born
in the plane I didn't care everybody get
on the plane first it doesn't matter all
I need is my seat yeah I don't need the
overhead space folks I can put it right
under my seat that's how I like to live
I've been minimizing one more I used to
bring different shoes [__] that now I'm
like I'm just gonna wear one pair of
shoes one pair of pants that's on me
right now yep you know one pair of
workout shoes one pair of shoes for the
show the shoes on your feet and then I
put workout shoes in my back hook us I
like hookah brand
um that's that's my shoe brand that I
like hookah Mach 3 whole cuts and and
gray running shoe and and they um and I
I put those in a couple pair of workout
shorts couple pair of undies the
underwear that I what I'll do is I'll
get go do my show wear those underwear
to sleep yeah and those socks to sleep
or sometimes I'll take one to two socks
off it depends wake up in the morning go
to the gym with the previously worn
underwear and socks workout nose stay in
those for as long as I can then shower
then change a pair of underwear and
socks to go do the next night and then
I'll continue that underwear that I
slept in you do it and repeat that's
what I'll do I'm not gonna waste under
I'm not going to waste clean underwear
for the gym I only wear dirty underwear
to the gym if I have a two-show night I
always go to the go to the club with a
second pair of underwear and a second
pair of socks and a second t-shirt just
you bring underwear and socks to The
Venue yeah and what's the reason
sometimes not socks but it's really not
that much extra the reason is because if
I'm at if I'm particularly animated or
the club's particularly hot and I'm
soaking wet and I gotta run on stage
again at that my comfort level sucks I
look ridiculous because I'm like
sweating you know what I mean and then I
I just hate you know because a lot of
times it's
right and I just hate sweating so if I'm
damp or wet from sweating for an hour I
fully change the one thing I skeeve in
this world the one thing that I truly it
makes my skin crawl is getting out of a
pool or ocean water and sitting in a wet
bathing suit I do not know how people
walk around all day get back in their
cars and drive home in a wet bathing
suit like this I know that a bathing
suit dries but that feeling of a wet
bathing suit is the most I don't know
especially at the beach oh a wet bathing
suit feeling is it's gross it's
disgusting people do it they sit in a
wet bathing suit all that yeah and you
start to get oh God I hate it I hate it
comfortable you know yeah yeah a wet
socks you can't do yeah I can't you know
I had the same thing and I found a
couple of bathing suits that literally
dry for real like on your body within
like 15 minutes how's that what what's
the technology it's just this material
that's thin and it just dries it's like
it's great even if you weren't like
toweling it in like 15 minutes the
shit's dry I also want to make a
statement to you yeah I'm done with the
beach
yeah I'm not a beach guy I think at this
point in 30 my 39th year of Life praise
be it Allah I will never be a beach guy
I do not like it at all I hate it even
more now with kids because the stress
level when you bring children to the
beach is at a fever pitch when you have
them in the pool it's maybe 90 percent
lower yeah because you could just carry
out the sand there's Riptides they get
lost they cut on a shell I cannot tell
you
I cannot tell you how much of a bad time
I had sitting at the beach with the kids
and how much of a good time I had
sitting at the pool with them yes and
it's funny because the beach is meant
strictly for relaxation yes and it it it
it it it it is the couldn't be I hate
the sand in my feet I hate the sand in
my bathing suit I hate the way my
bathing suit feels I hate that my kid
wants to jump in the water even though
they're sharks and Riptides I hate that
she the kids get mad because they said
the sand feels itchy I'm like well it's
sand there's bugs in the sand I gotta
forbid you sit with them to do a castle
when you're out of the water and then
you get that sand on you nope I don't
know now it's wet and sand I don't like
it at all there's Beach worms I'm not a
beach guy
I know that people no way dude no way
what would you do
what is that it's a it's a snake
but it's what does it mean scales and
skin and like the meat so that thing
those those exists wait a minute did he
just cut did he just cut the tail the
head off
or the tailor no what does that mean
no he has bait and the worm is coming up
to bite no and the worm is five feet
always so and there now is that a
surprisingly long one or they all kind
of are that long um
you're a beach guy right well I lived on
the beach for years that's what I'm
saying so are you a beach guy because
you live there
[Music]
because you don't strike me as a guy
you're in the summer in the blame you're
not you're not really going out there
that much you're staying in the city
you're like an urban these days you drop
these these things like it's nothing
you're like yeah I dropped out of school
in sixth grade I lived on the beach for
a while that's like we would live on a
trailer on the beach like a trailer park
in the Hamptons way in Montauk Montauk
but before my but this is before Montauk
was trending yeah you were like original
like like when it was just fishermen
yeah we would live on the beach in a
trailer from May to September did you
like it I loved it but I was a little
kid but now I'm kind of you know I
rarely go to the beach and then I was
like a servant so we wouldn't go to this
I want to do it yeah yeah I would feed
them on the beach all those little
bubbles those are sand fleas like
surfing would you surf like I did a
lesson once friends are surfing I'm like
so they're getting out there at six
o'clock in the morning they're going in
you know deep past the waves in the
ocean and just sitting in the ocean and
surfing waves I know but I'm like rocks
sharks I'm sure it's a natural high when
you're doing that that thing's falling
over you it's like nothing you've ever
felt can I just do that in the mall in
New Jersey you probably could yeah
the shark attack and Rockaway yeah no
well I saw a photo a cop took of the
victory I showed I showed it to you no
did someone die oh no but they're
missing like part of their ass yeah yeah
wait it's on it's on I don't know I
haven't found it online I have it too
yeah yeah
it's it's a reason oh yeah so the sharks
are coming now that's it this this
shocks all over the Eastern Seaboard all
over Long Island at right at the shore
level the attacks are up like 800
percent what is it and it's not gonna
stop because it's the water getting
warmer and now they took that from us
now we can even do that I'll go to a
beach that has pristine white sand and
Crystal teal see-through water like
Turks and Caicos and I could see
everything around me that's what I'm
relegated to now yep I grew up going to
the church
yeah it's probably the same is it
disturbing
I would say yes yeah is it is it the
Fallout or the attack itself no no
there's no video of the attack this is
this is them loading her into the
ambulance you know the police officer
was sitting in the ambulance or the EMT
he decided to take video of her a pick
oh my
it looks fake it looks like that looks
fake 25 pounds of Flesh
[Laughter]
uh what what bear
yeah um dealer's Choice okay well no
right because because anything anything
but a black bear and you're dead we're
talking about a bear in the woods not a
bear in the West Village I think
it's gonna be good shoes
I think even if bear cub would [__] up I
would to be honest with you I personally
think the quicker way is probably going
to be the shark because they'll drown
you the bear I think is gonna it's gonna
really suck right it's gonna but a shark
you said if you're being attacked right
odds are unless it's a black bear if a
bear if you see a bear that's not a
black bear and it runs out you die you
can survive a shark attack they could
nip you you know you could I mean I
don't know if this works but you punch
him in the nose whatever or they can
bite you and shoot them away okay or you
can break free you know I don't know I I
always think about it because I'm like
what would I do because I don't think
the punching you can't get you can't
punch underwater no so that to me is out
I'm thinking do I get a finger in his
eye I'm always thinking finger in the
eye do you ever see the time Stevo
almost lost the foot to a great white no
swam up from behind him and he actually
he didn't see it he accidentally kicked
it in the face and it left them alone
it's like insane footage of him yeah
well you ever seen the one when jackass
when they're laying in the middle of
like the African desert with all meat
hanging from a hammock and all those
tigers and and hyenas yeah
now they keep him away
dude I don't know jackass used to do
jackass used to do yeah crazy crazy
crazy [__] well we uh last year I hosted
uh Shark Week and uh they told us the
jackass had hosted it like the year or
two before and uh one guy jumped in like
a new guy like a new Jackass guy not
like the old cast he got shot out into
the ocean or whatever and he landed on
like it was a it was infested with
sharks and he landed on them and one bit
like his his hand off or whatever yeah
poopy that's his name his name is his
name is poopies my daughter named him
yeah uh literally I they had to like
take him out and like get him to he he
took his hand or whatever like he
doesn't have a hand no he took like he
severely severely injured like this
isn't poopy though is it
okay oh oh yeah yeah I mean like it
wasn't good it was like I don't know if
they're gonna show it but like
but it was bad is this the same water
you went and did his yeah it's the same
where is it Bahamas Bahamas so Bahamas
are infested with sharks
um
I guess that we at a certain place like
we weren't just hanging out by the beach
Montauk if you guys don't know the
geography
Montauk okay so I didn't realize this I
was told I know you guys probably know
this especially pimp being a more Beach
guy but this blew my mind you know it's
it's it's obvious but I didn't never
thought of it this way when you go out
into Long Island and Montauk at the end
okay you are actually because of the
geography you're 150 miles into the
ocean so there's sharks everywhere when
you go on the beach at Rockaway Beach or
Jones Beach you're on the coast you're
on the land so sharks aren't they're
there but not as much but when you're in
Montauk right more 150 miles in the
middle of the ocean you're jutting out
into the ocean right so you're in like
you're in the middle of the ocean yeah
you're already there [__] ocean
you're already there you're no belly
yeah it's like it's as if you had a FL
plane that was flying 20 minutes and
over the ocean yeah so
so there so my boy was like yeah that's
why there's sharks like jaws and all
that was these areas because these are
where the great wines are because you're
truly in the middle of the ocean maybe
we maybe you and I'm being serious but
maybe we like you swim now with a knife
like it could be a sharp medium-sized
knife that you know and I don't know you
zoom with it in your pocket and then
like no but I mean I mean seriously I
mean what's the best way to get some of
the gun like a shark's gonna come up to
me even if it bites me at least I can
stop okay but my thing is this but my
you tensed it or stab and pull like you
know yeah but how yeah I guess I don't
know
yeah I'm not gonna punch it you can't
punch from the top of the water through
the water hit his nose and do that I
heard that if you just like lightly tap
it even hit it like there's so much
nerve endings there that'll really mess
it up but my thing is why even go in the
ocean why can't you just sit on the sand
you know go with to your ankles why do
you have to go why why do you have to
with modern technology go in the actual
ocean why do you have to do that I feel
like uh if there was no ocean it was
just sand people wouldn't go to the
beach you know what I mean no I'm
serious like yeah like yeah then you're
in the desert but what's the point of
going to this beach and not go in the
water because you go to the beach in the
sad sun and you're just gonna bake out
there like a chicken cutlet and not have
any relief like people you gotta go to a
beach that has a pool if you don't go to
the people there are peaches have pools
not where I was in Montauk they have a
pool yeah so that's what you got to do
yeah because like you can't just go to
the beach and then sit there and then be
like well what now okay or so what you
could do that and is go in and just let
the waves hit you and and yeah you don't
have to go in swimming in the ocean to
me we don't belong there why yeah I just
don't and I know that some people want
to listen and by the way this is just my
opinion some like the surfer dude was
like I understand the risks I'm willing
to take them yeah I was like I don't
have a family I don't have kids I don't
know so I if I if that happened to me it
would happen I love the ocean all right
good for you for me I'm like I see no
logical reason why I need to go in the
water if I want to cool off I'll jump in
the pool
I'm I'm aiming for a natural uh death of
death by natural causes myself right I I
can't even imagine being like you want
to die in your sleep yeah natural causes
peacefully in my sleep God bless like
just like you know you ever seen these
people they die like in their early 30s
and cause this natural causes I'm like
what kind of Life were you living yeah
what is a natural cause by the way you
stop
your body literally gave out and give
out years yeah where was that shark oh
yeah yeah you could put that
oh we lost the TV
God damn it um
yeah I can't imagine imagine like okay
imagine me and you like right you know
me is it me and you or you and I you and
I okay but you could say me and you
we're we're not in mixed company right
but you wouldn't but you and I that's
what it would be yeah you and I so you
you know I right no but like picture
someone like me we have a relationship
it's long term we work together we hang
together we know each other's families
all that stuff I'm I'm your young guy
I'm never thinking about like how you're
gonna and how you're how your chat
stories ending imagine you go out and
you get bit and taken down in the ocean
by a shark and that's like you didn't
know but that was your destiny for your
40 years and you didn't even know that
just one day everything's normal same
life you have right now and all of a
sudden a shark just pulls you down and
that's it you you never seen again a
shark took you your family's left with
that that's in the obit yeah that's that
that's what we all have to deal with
people die that way it's insane the way
that people die I know I I just wanna
just natural cause out right you know
what I mean you guys ever think about
whaling I had to film a documentary on
the history of whaling because the
Hamptons was built on whaling yeah they
always go out in row boats teenagers
would go out in row boats and murder
whales with harpoons yeah dude that
that's why the Portuguese the Portuguese
were always going over there that's why
there's Portuguese [__] Montauk yeah
crazy dude murder a whale with a robo
you ever see those videos online or the
guy like in a kayak and all of a sudden
a whale comes up like next to him and
it's literally like it looks like he
like like the the freaking the the
Santiago aircraft carrier like it's like
they're so huge and then they just stay
still and it's like right under them and
it's like I mean one bite
not even with the they said whales are
so intelligent that if they wanted to
like if you grabbed its fin it would
swim 200 feet down immediately and just
Crush you and then swim up they know
they're small they're like they believe
whales are as smart as us yeah we just
have a different way of communicating
it's not wild that some animals they
think even octopus and things that we
eat are even smarter than us more
intelligent yeah yeah that's why I don't
eat those anymore all right I had I had
them at garny's last time the best thing
to do is stay calm and hover yeah you
can't give me give me a break man yeah
swim swimming will alert the shark
because they have a sensor along their
body that detects panicked movement if
you stay calm the shark may be
uninterested well they say good luck
they say sharks don't care and they
don't want to eat us they're more scared
they're more scared of us than we are of
them but that's [__] I know that
they want to eat us yeah or or even an
order if one wants to eat us how could
you not want to eat like that one is out
there right now yeah and people still
get bit I just can't believe like that I
just can't believe I I'm not gonna let
myself go by shark you know you won't
you won't have death by shark I will not
have d by us okay yeah I I don't I don't
see you dying I don't see you dying of I
see you dying actually of a natural
death yeah I do see natural causes in
the future you ever think about this
tell me if you've ever thought about
this and this has been said in like
ancient terms and way better cooler
verbiage but you ever think like anyone
who's dead at one point was alive they
were us they went through what we went
through and went through a whole life
like us and now they're dead and anyone
who's alive will eventually be dead
like have you ever thought about at the
reverse I know what you mean I know what
you mean and like even though we know
that when you stop to just think about
the magnitude of it or whatever or just
it's wild it's crazy yeah when you look
at someone even if you don't know them
and they're great if you're like the
exact same experience that I'm having
they had yeah and now that's over
and then that's what we will be yeah and
where and that to that person no I know
believe me it's all I think about really
actually it's truly it's truly all I
think about you think about death all
the time all the time I think it's
healthy to think about I'm having a joke
no I don't want to think I think it's
healthy to think about death but I don't
think about it I don't think about a
healthy a healthy Pace yeah see that
that's the issue I I I actually you know
I'm trying my best to not think about it
like I'm working on they're in therapy
about death you know not just thinking
about death yeah about uh imagining it
uh how it's gonna happen when why what
will that what will that do to the
people that know me or or people in my
life if they're gonna pass what's that
and I bring myself to that moment I
start to literally feel I start to
process those feelings of deep grief now
and it's like I shouldn't be anywhere
near that you know what I mean I'm
putting myself through it in a little
bit of a way now right never don't no
don't why true truly why suffer why
suffer twice you're going through yeah I
know you're going through it the same
thing as like why didn't you just stay
still when the shark was killing right
imagine like you do it's all this time
you think about it you have this you
know beautiful family and like you're
looking down at them at the funeral
everyone's so upset and I mean as soon
as your body's in the thing they're like
who's hungry yeah like right away that's
pretty much what happened they go they
go to like they have a big dinner and um
with by the time they get home they're
upset privately you know wife kids
whatever upset but everyone else is like
you know what a day it has to go on do
you want to live forever I don't
understand what you want
don't you feel like death anchors
reality
not necessarily I mean yes yes to an
extent but like well I don't want
anything tragic and I just you know but
I just want to be like fulfill old not
in any terrible pain and accepting of it
I'll never I'm working on the acceptance
and I don't think I'll ever get that I
wish it was like different like death
was like uh you know they let you know
when it is like a certain day and time
and then you just say goodbye to
everybody you hug them you kiss them and
you go through like a door and you close
it you never come back the appointment
that sounds worse that sounds worse does
it
yeah interesting yeah I know go get your
tarot cards right they'll tell you
they'll tell you should we get should we
get on a psychic 100 they'll tell you
exactly what you need to know readings
like Tower readings and I want to get
the Long Island Medium in here oh yeah
hello we got we got a famous one yeah
let's get the Long Island Medium in here
yeah I'm sure you know get in touch with
that we already are in touch with them
all right let's get the login medium
yeah let's get her in here with her hair
yeah yeah she she does go places with
her hair look at this natural causes you
ready this is [__] natural causes
death from natural causes might be a
heart attack stroke cancer infection or
any other illness
natural causes that's my heart attack
and cancer yeah I don't want those so
natural causes but or any other illness
so if I die of the Bubonic plague that's
just natural causes just not getting hit
by a truck yeah exactly is it anything
sometimes I just associated with like
you know everything's kind of just done
right now like it's almost like you know
rebooting like just turning off the TV
like I just I'm like oh you know like
everything's getting a little weak
everything's affecting everything hey
you know it's it's not one thing it's a
whole lot of some things and it's just
like all right
and I feel like that's what natural is
suicide all it is is not so suicide is
not natural causes then no no
but cancer is yeah because I guess you
have no part in the matter it's all
nature nurture yeah but then but the
argument is suicide might be that might
be an infection what would it say it's
even worse because I I was always like
just making myself believe that natural
cause is just meant like you went to bed
you didn't get up right you know like
not that you
you know what I mean like I don't want
any of those things either
yeah but
you can't suffer twice yeah so you gotta
just when it happens it happens you want
to say kill well I'll kill you
you want me to kill you you tell me when
it's a good when you can't take anymore
yes I can't take him I can do it yeah
yeah okay right gone boom back in that
bag easy I feel like people like
would more people would want to call the
shot of course and just be like you know
what well they have assisted suicide in
some countries yeah of course yeah do
you have you ever seen the Anthony
Bourdain documentary Roadrunner yeah I
watch it on the plane a couple days ago
what a fascinating documentary yeah I've
watched it now for the third time and
every time I watch it I like it because
so many people have had food shows or
whatever but nobody is even close to him
was it just his brutal honesty about who
he was and and like what is it about him
that that's the one you have to watch I
watch over and over and over again he's
a secret sauce I gotta be right right
even from do you ever read Kitchen
Confidential no I didn't did you I I
read excerpts uh my lady who read it and
she said it you have to read it's
wonderful it's really good really good
by the way no right no writing
experience no co-author he actually
himself wrote it uh every time somebody
will write tell him you're asking me no
I'm telling you okay yeah and I think a
lot of times people have ghost riders or
they write but he did it like no it was
fascinating too and we might have talked
about this is is again I've heard him
say this for but it just resonated with
me another way where he says like he's
in the back of a cab they're filming him
for
um like a documentary on him this is
from the mid 90s when Kitchen
Confidential just came out he was just
starting to get his Fame he hadn't even
done anything he hadn't even become
Anthony Bourdain yet right but he was
like you know I'm 43 years old and I
thought all my life's adventures were
passed I thought the fun I was going to
have was the fun I was gonna have and
that's it there's nothing happening he
didn't realize that the actual next you
know 15 years of his life were going to
be his life that's crazy isn't that wild
how like there's somebody there's
somebody out there right now that's in
their mid-40s that's going to be world
famous that right now is not yeah it's
gonna be me
it's crazy your daughter's husband's
walking around somewhere 100 [__] his
pants just now probably 100 you know
what I mean it's wow he's there he's
there he's somewhere he exists yeah and
and and my husband's walking around out
there somewhere they all exist it's
crazy yeah that is that is interesting
it is interesting that all the people
that you're ever gonna meet are probably
well no I guess that's a stupid thing to
say you know what I heard that's really
good that I actually I never thought of
it like that and I was like oh that's
really like
um uplifting or at least encouraging you
have not yet met all the people that you
will deeply love in your life wow yeah
unless you're gonna die tonight yeah
right
by natural by natural causes yeah but no
think about that like someone there's
still a multitude of people that are
going to come into your life and change
it for the better and you're gonna be
like that's one of the my the people I
love what we've said on this podcast
many times but it's good because as
Seneca says you never go through the
same river twice so I'll say it again
you are living the good old days are
happening right now yeah these the
things you will reminisce about is right
now it's happening so when you think
about the early 2000s late 90s it was
today yeah it was the same moment and
you're gonna only realize it so that's
why you got to try to stay in in the
moment and realize that you know the
technology is old right now yeah your
clothes are outdated right now yeah
right your haircut sucks right now you
you you look you look stupid right now
this has been hey babe
[Music]
hey babe hey babe
hey babe